lots to talk to Mel's dry Secretary of
State for work and pensions about them
this morning good morning good morning
it's great to see you thanks are you a
bit of a mover on the Dance Floor you
don't want to see me on the Dance Floor
I see I'm my young daughters would
concur with that okay talk to me about
what is going on with the French are we
nearing a deal with them well uh clearly
the Prime Minister has been engaged with
president macron and the government's
been engaged with the French government
to all sorts of different levels and my
understanding is we're in the final
stages of what could be an agreement
which would be very good news and I know
that the Prime Minister personally has
been absolutely on top of this a couple
of briefings a day in fact on the whole
crisis that we're looking at so let's
keep our fingers crossed the mood music
seems to be good at the moment and would
that involve British border Force being
posted with the French we'll have to
wait and see we'll have to wait and see
on what the any detail that emerges but
I think the good thing is I think there
has been a fundamental shift in tone
between ourselves and the French and of
course that's fun to any deal
um I just think the approach of Rishi
sunak has been one of close engagement I
think he's a person that gets right
across all the details so I suspect
having put a lot of personal time into
what the solutions might look like he's
probably come up with something that
might stand more chance of working than
might otherwise be the case so hopefully
I would think the French would see him
as somebody very serious somebody who
wants to work as a close partner in
solving a problem which of course is not
good for either country how close are we
sure do
I not actually in the room myself so I
can't oh you know comment but but
certainly what is being said is that we
appear to be in the final stages is the
language that I've heard of a Social
Deal week's days let's wait and see
let's wait and see but I I've no doubt
that the government is pressing on this
with uh with great Vigor
um Sola bravman the Home Secretary has
her own view on migrants that she's told
us quite a lot about yesterday we had
the former Home Secretary Grant chaps on
the program he appeared to throw her
onto the boss suggesting that the
government was in danger of breaking the
law and he changed the situation at
manston the Detention Center straight
away the first moment he got in to power
why did she not do it well I I don't
know all the ins and outs of exactly the
decisions that Sue Ella made but I do
know that the Prime Minister has
confidence in her she's made some
mistakes in the past she's apologized
for that the priority Now is really to
look forward and if you look at what has
happened in recent times things have
improved so we've gone down from 4 000
migrants at the manston center which is
massively over the capacity down to 1600
which is at the capacity so progress is
being made but I don't think anybody
would suggest there isn't still quite a
long wait no I understand that but just
to take you back to the point that I was
trying to make I mean the government
can't have been in danger of breaking
the law one day in the previous day not
well as I say I don't know all the
intricacies of all the decisions that
were taken absolutely well certainly
soiler bravaman uh I believe is is
stating very clearly that she didn't do
anything that would have been in breach
of the law but as I say what I think
really matters now is that we get on top
of the situation at manston Robert
General second and the Home Secretary
have been very closely involved now in
studying that situation and it seems to
me that in Fairly short order after what
was a huge surge of migrants coming
across the Davis Straits they have
actually started get on on top of that
and I think that's the most important
thing at the moment now there's a lot of
more work to do as we know working with
our French partners and other approaches
to solving what is a multi-faceted issue
with migration but it is an absolute top
priority and I've no doubt that through
time we will start to see Improvement do
you acknowledge that it would be a
surprise for the um the advice from
officials to have changed within 24
hours well as I say I I'm not close
enough to know what the advice may or
may not have been what these
circumstances on the ground were so I
can't really comment on that other than
to say that I think the most important
thing now is that we continue to make
the Kinder progress uh that we've seen
in the last week
um what sort of man is Gavin Williamson
um I think he's somebody who has some
significant strength I think he
understands government very closely he
was PPS to David Cameron when he was
prime minister so he's somebody who
would have an understanding of the
workings of the Parliamentary party and
of Parliament and know a large number of
colleagues so I think those are strength
strengths that Gavin has
it doesn't seem a particularly Pleasant
bloke or boss
well I actually served in the whips
office under Gavin Williamson and there
was always this great aura of you know
do you remember cranus the spider the
tarantula Etc and the reality with with
cronuses he was much touted
um but he never actually was released to
bite anybody so that was how I always
saw uh Gavin as somebody had this sort
of aura or a Mystique around him but the
reality was he just generally got on
with his job and I can only speak from
my own experience okay and that was how
I found him working oh he's since
morning for over a year that he sends to
women haven't we and we also suggestions
that he vehemently denies that he tells
somebody to Slit their throat and
somebody else to jump out of a window
well if that is the case that that is
utterly utterly unacceptable but at the
moment it is in the realm of media
speculation there is an independent
inquiry as you know going on around
another incident alleged incident
between himself and the then Chief whip
Wendy Morton and I think the important
thing we do now is not to start in being
in this government minister in a pining
on who's right and wrong and what may or
may not have happened but to wait for
the results of that investigation and
then when we have that and any other
investigation that may be triggered in
the meantime then I think we can take
stock and come to a firm conclusion
who's going to carry out that
investigation well the independent
parliamentary authorities so the
complaint as I understand it was made by
Wendy Morton about Sir Gavin Williams
we're seeing the text yes at that point
it was it was a party matter because it
was made to conservative party central
office and so we'll go through that
process but it will be independent and
it will be thorough and it will come to
a firm conclusion I have no doubt and
the suggestion was that the Prime
Minister knew about it at the time and
yet still gave him a job well I
understand what he knew was that there
had been a disagreement between Wendy
Morton and Gavin Williamson but what he
didn't know was the substance of the
allegation in other words he hadn't at
that point for example seen the texts uh
that are now uh out in the public I'm
surprised that he wouldn't have asked to
see that I mean it would have been me
I'd have asked to see well it depends I
think if somebody came to you and said
look just just to let you know prime
minister these two individuals have had
a disagreement and it's rather heated
Etc uh amidst the world of a busy day
and lots of appointments and other
things going on you might be forgiven
for not necessarily drilling down and
demanding all the detail immediately
what do you think particularly if at
that point it was as I believe it was
subject of an independent investigation
that would perhaps be further reason why
you wouldn't actually say I want to see
all the evidence what did you make of
the content of those WhatsApp messages
well unacceptable unacceptable I mean to
adopt that kind of language from that
kind of tone is clearly not acceptable
and to be fair to Gavin he has
apologized and recognized that whilst he
may have been frustrated at the time it
was inappropriate to respond it it
wasn't just one particular when he was
Hush on the car well as I say he he has
accepted uh that it was not the right
way uh to proceed and and I've just
answered a question very direct by
saying I don't think it was appropriate
yeah is he unsackable
well I don't think anybody's on the sack
well I'm not on sackable as we've seen
the recent past even prime ministers are
not unsackable so I think the answer to
that is we are We Are all uh sackable at
some point
um depending on the search I mean you're
doing really badly in the polls though
aren't you down again in the latest poll
of 20 odd Point difference between you
and labor doesn't help when you have
people like Gavin Williamson
um in government does it really well
we've seen actually an improvement of
our position of the poll now admittedly
from a very very 48 27 yes from a very
low base I'm just going to make that
point but it is nonetheless beginning to
go in the right direction there are
several things that we've got to get
right and one of them is migration uh
there are very serious issues around the
Health Service that Steve Barclay is
working on and beginning to address and
of course there's a central issue of the
economy and we'll heal from the
chancellor on the 17th of November uh
the the fiscal plan if you like and the
obl forecasts around that to settle
things down and give us that direction
of travel on the economy and my feeling
is that as we start to make progress in
that area those areas we will start to
see further progress against labor and
get ourselves back into Political
contention but I do accept that we have
a very long way to go and there's an
awful lot of work to be done I think
that was your opportunity to mention why
you're here as well this morning well
yes some good news okay because I mean
mentioned the Chancellor's work now of
course that's going to be very tough
choices around tax and spending and lots
of difficult things that the
government's going to have to do but
within that the government's core
mission is to look after the vulnerable
to make sure that those that are less
well-off are as protected as possible
from The Fallout from the war in Ukraine
or the spike in Energy prices and so on
and so that means we're making in total
650 pound uh payment to low-income
households that's 8 million households
up and down the country and the second
Trust of that is literally going out
between today and the end of this month
it will be of a huge help to millions of
people and it is not the only thing that
we're doing of course it's part of a
much wider support package so there's a
400 pound Discount Energy bills so
there's targeted support for the
vulnerable 150 pounds for those who are
disabled 300 pounds for pensioners
there's also the energy price guarantee
so we're making sure that average Energy
bill don't exceed two and a half
thousand pounds is a local Authority
fund for discretionary got it support so
it's important though this is a huge
let's talk about Boris Johnson the cop
is that a help or a hindrance well Boris
is perfectly uh entitled to go to cop as
with many conservations because I didn't
see it that way I think at the end of
the day you know he was a prime minister
who believed very strongly in the green
agenda in net zero and was incredibly
enthusiastic about the potential that
the economy has for benefiting uh from
the green technologies uh of the future
so I it doesn't surprise me uh that he's
there
um and I don't see why he shouldn't be
well he created a U-turn didn't he buy
it for our own prime minister who said
he wasn't going to go and now
um he said he wanted to concentrate on
the economy now he's decided he will go
after all when I interviewed um Rishi
sunak in the summer he told me that he's
first overseas trip would be to Ukraine
it's not so what does that say to the
people of Ukraine well sometimes I think
too much can be set by exactly who tools
to who first or who visits country uh
first one always has to get a balance
between you know what you would ideally
like to do and what circumstances
dictate I think it was very important
that he went to Sharm El Sheikh and uh
he clearly did as well because despite
all the pressures that he's under
working with the chancellor for the
statement on the 17th he has gone he has
made a Major Impact there he has
underscored our commitment uh to Net
Zero to delivering on the Glasgow uh cop
and the commitments uh that we made then
I think it was important that he did so
and I think probably personally to him
it was important that he went to he's
going to Ukraine there isn't he
well let's see these ten notches the
Amber told us yesterday that he was well
well then it must be true let let's see
uh about that I mean visits tend to be
because of the security
um
talking about security what um what
about this stop oil protesters what
we're going to do about them
well I I do think that there's a there's
a major issue when individuals can go on
to motorways or even just outside
parliament in fact uh periodically at
will just sit down in the middle of the
road and disrupt the traffic sometimes
indeed Emergency Services get caught up
in that as well so the government is uh
moving to the point where we're having
the tools to be able to
um deal with that through legislation uh
and it will then be a case of government
working with the police and within the
legal framework uh so that we're able to
intervene in a in a more robust manner
to make sure that these kind of things
are less destructive than they are at
the moment have they got a point though
they have got a point haven't they well
they do in the sense like there's a
couple of points here okay I think one
is absolutely
um we are all determined and this
government above all else is absolutely
determined to Bear Down on the use of
fossil fuels and you can see that in the
diminished use of coal for example the
way that we have ramped up Renewables
not least offshore wind we've made huge
progress as a government and we've got
to keep that going second point I would
make is that we do have to strike the
right balance between the right of
individuals to express their opinion and
protest which is absolutely fundamental
to a civilized democracy which is what
we have in in our country and at the
other time making sure that we don't
inconvenience the public or indeed in
danger the public in some circumstances
and that's the kind of balanced approach
that the government is taking to strike
the right balance between these
particular objectives are you a football
fan I'm not hugely into what my wife
supports Liverpool so if Liverpool were
playing I do show an interest in
Liverpool but I can't say I have a local
team though what do we think about
um the uh situation in Casa we've had
several guests on over the last couple
of days saying that you know we really
shouldn't be playing there and it's
totally inappropriate the way that
people who are gay are treated in a
place like Qatar whereas James cleverley
has said the foreign secretary that we
should respect uh the rules of the
country that we're going to
well I I think you can work with the
rules of the country that you go to
because that is their law but you don't
have to approve and I know that uh
registrations have been made by the UK
government to the Qatar authorities
around the issues that you're mentioning
because from my point of view on the
government's point of view those things
are wrong on the issue of sport and
politics I personally tend to lean into
believing that we should have the sport
and deal with the politics separately
and I would apply that also to the
Olympic Games and boycotts and so on
um but you know these are serious issues
and they are issues that the government
is and has been taking up final question
before I let you go a couple of weeks
ago last Friday I was speaking to
Anne-Marie trevelyn outside dining
Street and I said do you think this
trust will still be in power by the time
I came back from my holidays she didn't
even last the day do you think Gavin
Williamson will still be in government
by Christmas
well I'm not going to speculating on
anybody's future I suspect the answer to
that is yes because there is an
investigation that will take some time
and we've got to wait to see what comes
out of that the Prime Minister
um has made it uh clear that he's an
important member who's a cabinet we
discussed earlier some of the uh
strengths that he has and as an
individual and the important thing now
is that the the uh the cabinet which is
broadly drawn from right across the
Parliamentary party uh works together
um closely together drawing on all the
talents we we have and and Gavin most
definitely has a number of talents in
order to do the very best that we can
for the British school he's going
nowhere at a difficult time yeah I must
let you go it's always great to talk to
you thank you very much joining us thank
you